lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar sobre la configuración
electrónica de un átomo que no se
encuentre en el bloque s&p sino que sea
un elemento del bloque t y para eso
usaremos la tabla periódica pero vamos a
reordenar la un poco cambiemos al helio
del lugar tiene sentido que esté aquí ya
que es un gas noble es inerte pero como
la configuración electrónica más alta
del helio se encuentra en la sub capa s
su configuración electrónica es 1 s 2 lo
pondré de este lado con los elementos
del bloque s lo pegaré justo aquí a qué
me refiero con bloque s bueno significa
que en cada uno de estos elementos
aunque hay excepciones la energía
electrónica más
alta de estos elementos se encuentra en
la sub capa electrónica s
por eso se le llama el bloque s
por ejemplo la energía electrónica más
alta del potasio se encuentra en la sub
capa 4 s mientras que la del hidrógeno
se encuentra en la sub capa 1 s sigue
siendo ese ahora esto nos permite
dividir el resto de la tabla periódica
en otros bloques de este lado tenemos el
bloque p y ocurre lo mismo en general la
energía electrónica más alta en la
configuración electrónica de estos
elementos se encuentra en la sub capa de
entonces este es el bloque p y quizá ya
adivinaron que este bloque de en medio
es el bloque d
este es el bloque de y este es el bloque
efe pero lo veremos en otro vídeo ahora
esto de qué nos sirve bueno si algo se
encuentra en el bloque de podemos decir
que su energía electrónica más alta
estará en la sub capa de por ejemplo en
el caso del hierro para el hierro la
energía electrónica más alta se
encuentra en la sub capa de la sub capa
de empieza a ser muy interesante porque
para algo que se encuentre en la sub
capa s&p como por ejemplo el oxígeno
podemos decir ok el oxígeno se encuentra
en el bloque p así que su energía
electrónica más alta estará en la sub
capa 2 p incluso podemos conocer su
configuración
1 s todos 2 s 2 y luego 1 2 3 4 24 vamos
a escribirlo entonces para el oxígeno
tenemos la sub capa 1 s 2 llena después
tenemos la sub capa 2 s 2 también
estamos en el segundo período y después
tenemos 1234 electrones en la sub capa 2
p pero como supe que es 2 p bueno porque
recuerden que estamos en el segundo
periodo o segunda fila de la tabla
periódica por eso es 2 p2p 4 entonces 1
s 2 2 s 2
uno dos tres cuatro ahora quizá quieran
hacer lo mismo para la configuración
electrónica de digamos hierro donde
iniciamos con cuatro s dos y luego han
de pensar que sigue 4 de 14 de 24 de 3 y
así consecutivamente
pero en realidad la sub capa de se
empieza a llenar desde la tercera capa
así que lo importante a recordar cuando
no sepan que su capa están llenando por
ejemplo en el caso del hierro en este
caso el hierro se encuentra en el cuarto
período pero para la sub capa de
tomaremos ese período menos 1 es decir
que la energía electrónica más alta no
estará en la sub capa 4 d sino que
estará en la sub capa
de trataré de explicarlo mejor
escribamos toda la configuración
electrónica para el hierro hierro
vamos a ver tenemos 1s 2 2 s 2
y luego tenemos el bloque p para llegar
hasta la configuración electrónica del
neón entonces tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 en el
bloque p así que nos queda 26 y después
llegamos a la tercera capa en donde
tenemos 3s 2 y luego llenamos la sub
capapé que sería 36 para llegar hasta la
configuración electrónica del argón 36
muy bien después pasamos a 4s 2 y ahora
para el bloque p
no vamos a llenar la sub capa 4 d sino
que llenaremos la 3d porque recuerden
que para el bloque t
tomamos el periodo menos 1 como estamos
en el cuarto periodo llenamos la sub
capa anterior
así que la regla general es que
empezamos a llenar las sub capas 3 de 13
de 23 de 3 3 de 4 3 de 5 y 3 de 6
entonces tenemos 3 de 6
esta es la configuración electrónica
llegamos hasta la sub capa de y esto es
muy interesante porque cuando pensamos
en los electrones que se encuentran
lejos del núcleo son estos electrones en
la cuarta capa de electrónica pero
cuando pensamos en los electrones con la
energía electrónica más alta esos son
los electrones que se encuentran en la
sub capa 3 de 6 otra forma de pensar en
esto es con los modelos en tres
dimensiones de los orbitales ahí se
puede ver la distribución de los
electrones dependiendo de su estado de
energía
así que los electrones exteriores son
los que están en la sub capa 4 s 2 pero
los electrones con energías más altas
son los que se encuentran en la sub capa
3 d